hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments mark I love you so oh my god
your butt is on fire oh god I should sit
on my butt that would been more
appropriate for the situation oh you're
amazing mark attempt eighty jumping
jacks and then describe how tired you
are in three words you can do it okay
Tim let me see if I can do it okay okay
ready can you sing the one punch man
theme song while punching a punching bag
pleae has mark you've said hundreds of
times that you hate strip clubs and I
think you've even said you had a story
on that if so would you mind telling us
yeah I guess I don't mind telling you
guys it was uh it was probably the first
time I've ever been in Las Vegas and if
you know Las Vegas you know that they
have a lot of strip clubs and things are
shady as [ __ ] when you go out there so I
was there for fourth of July with my
buddies and we were out at a club or a
bar or something like that and they were
really drunk and I was slightly drunk
and then they found out that the strip
club will pick you up in a limo if you
call so we called I did not want to go I
wanted to go home because I was
extremely tired but they wanted to go it
was my friend's birthday
Yatta Yatta Yatta we end up going and
then the limo dumps us out in the
shadiest part of town we go like off the
strip for a while and we pull up in this
back alley and they kick us out of the
limo it's the back of a building in an
alley looks horrific ly Shady there's
like big burly bouncers
standing outside checking IDs like the
limo is nice and then all sudden here's
reality it's horrifying and so I was
really regretting it at this point and
then we get in the strip club and it's
just so disgustingly dirty just it's
like packed in there with just guys and
it's just like shoulder-to-shoulder guys
and it's just like chest to back guys
like I've been to gay clubs before and
it was less packed at the club than it
was at the strip club so it was just
horrible in all aspects and personally I
don't get any enjoyment out of that
environment I wouldn't even get
enjoyment out of it if there was just
girls up on the stage doing their dances
and then trying to exploit me for money
because that's that's all they do and I
got nothing against strippers it's
they're out there that's their job but
it's also fake like it's just entirely
fake the experiences fake they don't
actually have any appreciation for you
and again no offense to strippers out
there who may or may not be watching my
videos but it was like it's just so fake
and I hated it and every moment of it
was just agonizingly bad and I was
sitting in a corner just moping and like
girls would go up to me like hey you
want a lap dance it's not the girl that
came up to me but I was like no I don't
I don't spend my money and then before I
got two words out of my mouth they were
already walking by which just was like
yeah if I don't have money then they
don't want to spend any time with me and
then it's just awful and I was in such a
bad mood and my friends who like 3/4 of
them I don't even talk to anymore were
just like high-fiving each other like
yeah bro I'm so good it was like sitting
in the back of the taxi just like moping
and grumpy and then we get back because
it was just bad all around so I don't
like that was a terrible strip club
experience but just in general I don't
find any joy out of that it's just so
fake like every part of it it's just a
fake experience I'd rather just go talk
to real girls not see whoa hey back help
us I'm not saying strippers aren't real
girls but I mean like real girls that
you could actually have a chance of
having an interesting conversation not
that you couldn't okay I'm gonna stop
right now mark
you make up a story that included a
breakdancing unicorn on a pogo stick
yeah sure this is the tragic tale of
BOGO the pogoing unicorn one day BOGO
was pogoing his heart out on a pogo
stick and he was bouncing up and down
the hill of rainbows and there was sun
shining all over the land but BOGO
didn't know that pogos aren't supposed
to go up hills so he did a no-no with
BOGO in the Pogo and then he fell down
the hill and broke his horn and you
don't want to break your horn on a hill
with your Pogo so BOGO had to go go to
the hospital where his Pogo was also
broke oh and he the doctor said no no
more pogo for BOGO and BOGO was like oh
no my Pogo and my horn Oh is broken the
end and then he dies vvv end mark would
you or have you ever put your hair in a
ponytail like that he and I adorable
mark what happened to your monthly
livestreams when is your next charity
livestream you're right you're
absolutely right I have fallen out a
pattern with that and it's you know I
couldn't make excuses for it because
there's been a lot going on in the past
few months and like I keep saying that
I'm gonna be starting them up again but
you're absolutely right I have not been
doing my monthly live streams like I
have said I would this weekend I'm gonna
be busy and the next weekend I'm gonna
be out of town but the following weekend
after that which I believe is the
weekend of Friday the 19th we will
schedule our next charity livestream for
the 20th on Saturday and then I might do
it like a two-parter like some like six
hours on Saturday and then six hours on
Sunday so people can visit both times
give me suggestions in the comments
below for what charity I should do for
the next one
thanks when are you going to get a pole
installed in your house so we can get
another pole dancing video oddly enough
like I actually was thinking about this
just yesterday I've been doing tons of
rock climbing and my hands are very torn
up about it but I've been getting a lot
of upper body strength as I've oddly
been saying to almost all of my friends
I could crush a baby's skull in my hand
the moment my grip strength is so strong
and I don't know I continue to use that
analogy the very strange and slightly
worrying that pushing baby's skull but I
will probably do another pole dancing
video very soon because I imagine that I
have been getting a lot more upper-body
strength well I don't even imagine it
I've been making a lot of progress at
the gym and soon enough I'll do my
sports mark boy cover shoot to do for my
athletic build and you guys are gonna
really be enticed and discussed it at
the same time for various reasons that I
won't explain ok mark what u.s. city
would you blow up in order to get
unlimited chicken and dumplings well
I've already blown up Detroit so I got
to pick another one after that Thanks
Detroit's already blown up can I can I
double bang kinda double bang Detroit
you know now limited chicken and
dumpling this is a big step up from just
a cake
cuz I'm pretty sure I blew up the trade
for either a cake or a pie so unlimited
tell ya blow it up again pull the Hunger
Games on that [ __ ] oh how does one find
the dankest of means in the darkest of
times in your darkest of alleys in the
deepest of valleys don't find a
mark personally I'm not subscribed to
your channel but I've watched a great
number of your videos and it always
touches me to see how much you truly
care about your subscribers I wish you
the best mark in life and on YouTube
keep up the amazing work well thank you
very much it's totally fine if you're
not actually subscribed in my videos
because well I mean I've said this a few
times I never imagined I would have
eleven million some odd subscribers I
never imagined that I come this far
because when I first started having ten
thousand or having a hundred thousand
was mind-boggling me and Wade used to
talk about it all the time because like
if you put all those people in one place
like you would overflow a sports stadium
with a hundred thousand people and
getting up to eleven a million it gets
harder and harder to comprehend that
number and I'm honored
I really am honored and I I never want
to come across insincere when I say that
because I say it's so much but I am I'm
honored that anybody watches my videos
and and it's touching that people get so
much joy out of my videos and I said
this in the last video as well it's just
like people come up to me and they say
that my videos helped them and the fact
that I entertain people is one thing but
the fact that people say I help them
it's another thing entirely and I I
really try never to take advantage of
that relationship that I have with you
guys which is why like I'm totally in
the wrong about not doing my charity
livestreams that's very important to me
I mean I've been selling shirts for
charity on and off but that's just
because I haven't had time to do it
myself but you're right like I have to
do those charity livestreams and I have
to be more engaged with you guys to tell
you guys just how much I actually do
care and I do I really really really
care about you guys and I really care
about the community that we've built
together and I care that we keep that
message moving forward because like
obviously my channel is not gonna last
forever it'll fall out of popularity or
some other youtuber will come up that's
better than me that's fine I I don't
mind that I don't mind that happening or
losing audience like that but while I
have you guys here
I have to have a commitment to you guys
in the videos that I put out and I have
to have a commitment meant to you guys
in the original goal that I had for this
channel which was to spread joy and do
good so as long as I keep doing those
things and I will then this is a good
thing we're doing so anyway thank you so
much for watching what if I told you
YouTube was ending what would you do
wow this kind of flows into the last one
um honestly I have no idea a lot of
people tell me that I should be a voice
actor just because I have a great voice
but honestly I want to make sure that
the next thing I do has the same kind of
impact for the world then what I do now
does I mean I may not even be in the
public eye and Lord knows that I don't
want to be in public office but whatever
I do I want to make sure that I actually
can make a difference in the world and
try to change it for the better because
I have a philosophy that I'm not gonna
live forever I don't want to live
forever I've I've said that many times
throughout the videos that I've done and
I want to make sure that at the end of
my life I can look back at all the
things that I've done and all the
choices that I make it's really weird
that I keep looking up and I forget that
I have this up here but it's true even
as silly as I look right now I want to
be able to look back and know that the
things I did matter and the people that
I influenced take that to heart and move
on with it which is why talking with you
guys like this and spreading this
message of just spreading joy and doing
good for your fellow neighbor even if
they're in the same country another
country like we're all part of the same
world as far as we know like this is the
only chance we're gonna get so we got to
make the best of it now and not let like
greed and and your corruption get the
best of things because there's a big
world here there's enough for everyone
to live well and we need to make sure
that you know those who have been less
fortunate than others get an equal
footing and have the chance for a good
life
and that's all that I really want to see
out of the world so I don't know what
I'd do but I just wanted to make a
difference where is dark applier right
here okay so that was reading your
comments number 19 I believe it is so
thank you everybody who submitted a
comment I had a great time reading
through them remember tell me what
charity you want the next charity
livestream to be for down in the
comments below and if you want your next
comment read thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see in the
next video bye bye